as men we deal with this
oh oh please i have not even wait let me
laugh bro i'm sitting in the air like
what my man said let me laugh
hold on
you see this this this is what this this
is so hard for a man to explain because
where
all right do you go through periods
every month yes do you chemically change
every month yes are you emotionally
unstable every month
yes
no
situations i don't know i don't answer
like a girl no come on
like come on this guy
as well he's making a point but listen
you have a period listen listen
i've been around to be honest oh come on
no no to be honest but we have to be
honest we can't just we can't generally
speak into the mic we can't generalize
i've had many girlfriends many links
many whoever just as you have but in my
personal experience they've never
treated me differently or acted
differently to a point where i can say
you're emotionally
unbalanced because you're on your period
to me i'm not saying it doesn't happen
i'm not saying it doesn't happen but in
my experience in general why are you
shaking your hands
he said not in general but we're dealing
with generals hold on hold on
it's what you gotta say i'm going here
on the cheating topic right
i'm saying we just need to be honest
right if i'm in a marriage and my wife
takes a penis in her vagina and i leave
i can't be the one to blame for breaking
the would you take would you carry the
blame if your wife cheated and you and
you divorced just yes do you want me to
answer the question before i've even
landed on my main point oh sorry i mean
i don't know
you don't have a period so you wouldn't
know if a woman has an emotional i mean
a um would you call it a a different
chemical experience from a period yeah
they release a hormone yeah which makes
them chemically different
that okay you don't that doesn't change
that that's facts yeah i'm not
challenges all right so i'm saying
that yeah so i'm saying as a man
when a woman goes through that certain
time of the month we are conditioned to
kind of
adjust navigate
her feelings yeah
so a woman in her brain
does understand that a certain time
a chemical changes in her head where she
does not act normal
but yet she can't understand the same
chemical not the same chemical but the
same
chemical reaction happens in a man where
he can't control but you can
control
you can control because when you're at
work and your period pain you could be
very nice to your boss but as soon as
you come home to your husband it's like
ah it's like no no you know you don't
have to control it
where are you getting that from yeah i
don't know where you're getting that
information from which part of the
information
if i'm one i'm on one everywhere like no
no one is is like everyone so you're
trying to tell me if you wanna if you're
on your period and you're feeling very
irritable you're gonna take it out on
your manager a hundred percent come on
man is that is that is that the average
okay okay you don't know how to control
your emotions at work
i i don't have to if i if i if i don't
want to i won't
i don't know man that's not okay this is
what i'm saying like i feel like it's
incomparable i feel like
i feel like
the concept of a person feeling hurt
because you've broken the marital vows
and in in comparison to
and and and
her being put in a condition where we're
telling her to deal with it in
comparison to a man dealing with his
partner on her period is very they're
very difficult
you answer the question please about um
if
so the marriage is there
we're all happy families and i've went
out yeah and i've cheated yeah
so you're gonna stay with me no that's
right
hold on hold on
the feelings of the kids first don't you
as a man one at a time guys
what so all i'm trying to say is on a
human level right everybody would be
hurt if i'm in a marriage my wife don't
need to have to have sex if she kisses a
guy if she sucks his dick and i know and
i leave do you think i'm going to accept
from society that i'm the one who
brought
anyone who says that
be realistic really i think i think in
all situations that it would be on the
woman like they would say
she broke if she broke up the family no
forget i'm saying you if you leave
okay first of all if your wife sucks
another man's dick
what are you doing staying or leaving
you but
no no no no no
no no no
i'm leaving
guys guys it has to be one at a time
we've got away from something
as a man you can leave and the kids can
still not suffer because if the woman
has cheated and the man leaves how she
conducts herself and how the man
conducts himself around the kids will be
what dictates whether the kids suffer or
not it's not about whether you leave or
how she treats the kids afterwards or
how she is around the kids whether she's
her i agree but the topic was based on
the woman dealing with the effects of
the manchet and the blame being on her
if she acts differently so on that same
topic if you act differently if your
wife has had another man's dick in her
mouth
naturally you would there's no there's
no manual yeah it's completely different
let me explain to you why my brother
first of all yeah more than likely
you're the person going down on one knee
so you have decided that a that's my
wife right yeah she could wait until
kingdom come for you to go down on me
and you don't have to go down on me
right so that means you've committed to
her yeah right and she's accepted your
commitment yeah yeah
knowing who you are and she knows what a
man is like already she knows you're a
predisposition yeah correct or no yeah
right so when you act out on that
predisposition that she already knows of
she is already calculating in her head
the way out of it
because she's already hypergamous so i'm
going for a rich man knowing that he's
going to cheat
knowing that i'm going to take him for
half his stomach
hold on
hold on yeah i know that i'm going to
i'm going to go with a man that's highly
likely going to cheat correct or no not
necessarily ask these girls and they
will tell you highly likely a man is
going to cheat or a man is thinking
about cheating so it's hard when the
woman is saying yes i do or yes i i do
want to marry she's already considering
it
i agree with him and this and the point
that a woman will know the type of value
man she's getting with has the ability
to exercise his options i don't know
hold on everybody knows that
so
yeah she's weighed up a risk
as to whether this is possible now
here's my here's my other guy if not if
i'm getting married to rihanna i'm
weighing up my wrist are you going to
marry a hoe of course i'm not going to
marry you right so but she's going to
marry a hodo
yeah right she's not basically hold on
hold on look think of that understanding
you're not going to marry a whole yeah
she would marry your whole and that's
the difference
guys
okay let's say that's that's the case
but you can't eliminate human emotion
and human reasoning of course you can't
say because you knew he's a man and he's
not naturally monogamous it's you should
have known that there was a high chance
of this is ridiculous like
listen guys you have a son and you have
a daughter
the in the exact same situation the guy
the daughter's husband cheats the son's
wife cheats it doesn't matter who's a
male or who knew what you're both
feeling for you're feeling for them
equally regardless of the whether one's
a male ones or feet like you're not i'm
giving them different advice though yeah
of course but i'm saying you're removing
the human reaction just a natural
response but we're not taught like
it's just why are you bringing the
emotion into it no because like because
we're talking
no because the whole thing like it's
just like i feel like i'm a girl like
why are you bringing this into it
obviously obviously they're going to
have an emotional reaction we know
you guys are overlooking the emotional
reaction and saying it's the woman the
woman is to blame for breaking up the
money yes i'm saying i'm saying i'm
saying women leave seventy to eighty
percent of the time ninety percent of
their college educated and i'm saying
women put their feelings before their
own kids